have you ever wanted to deal a thousand
damage to all of your opponents in one
go well thanks to this new card the
Millennium calendar from Lost Cavern of
Exelon now you can the Millennium
calendar is a one Mana legendary
artifact that says whenever you untap
one or more permanence during your untap
step put that many time counters on the
Millennium calendar pay two and tap
double the number of time counters on
the Millennium calendar and when there
are a thousand or more time counters on
the Millennium calendar sacrifice it and
each opponent loses 1,000 life now there
are two ways you can build a second in
standard the first involves playing all
will be one getting the calendar to at
least 20 counters and then simply
activating it to ding your opponent for
20 or more however in this video we're
going to do it the honest and true way
and get this calendar to a th counters
and important thing to keep in mind is
the calendar only needs nine activations
at most after has a single counter on it
now Y Man 5 on Twitter has pulled
together this Bank list that looks to
untap the calendar with teiri who slows
the sunset effectively reducing the
number of turns this combo takes by half
the deck also includes two excellent new
cards one of them being Sentinel of the
nameless City a three minor 34 with
vigilance that creates a map token
whenever it etbs or attacks a map token
is an artifact that you can pay one mana
and activate it at sorcery speeds and
Target creature will explore Sentinel is
great on the offense as well as being on
the defense to protect our plains
walkers and life totals the map that
Sentinel creates also goes great with
dusk Rose Relic a one Mana artifact with
an additional cost of sacrificing an
artifact or creature it has War Two and
can Exile an artifact or creature until
it leaves the battlefield the deck also
contains a few Manors ORS as well as a
couple of other Mana rocks that can help
us ramp into an early tfairy or storm
the Festival of course we're also
running the wandering Emperor to protect
our Plaines Walkers and get rid of some
large aggressive threats now that we've
covered the basics of the deck let's
jump into a quick game from the early
access event to start we have a pretty
okay opening seven we have the lands we
need am manad d the calendar and tfairy
however our only green Source com into
play tapped which means we can't drop
calendar on turn
one our opponent just plays a forest and
passes the turn we draw into the emperor
play our second land and cast root coil
creeper with the goal of playing T Fury
and the calendar on turn
three our opponent drops them own Mana
do 2 looks like they could be on the
monog Green Stompy plan we draw into
dream rout Cascade play it and just like
we planned Master Fury activate his plus
one to untap our land and our creature
and play the
calendar our opponent follows this up
with the new pugnacious Hammer skull a
three Mana 66 that when it attacks if
you don't control another dinosur you
put a stun counter on it we tap our root
coil creeper at the end of turn just so
the calendar gets an extra counter on
it for our fourth turn we draw another
dream rout Cascade and we play a darker
Wast so we can have double White open to
cast the wandering Emperor if we need to
and thanks to tier's plus one ability we
effectively get a free activation of the
calendar our opponent then casts a
hulking Raptor a four Mana 53 with ward
two that generates two green Mana at the
start of the pre-combat main phase which
will allow our opponent to ramp into
into more
dinosaurs it also lets them attack with
hammer skull without it getting a stun
counter they then attack arery and we
simply Exile it with the
emperor we unfortunately draw into
another land but if we can protect this
teiri for one more turn we can ultimate
him and likely win the game with
calender
our opponent plays an earthshaker dread
Mo a six Mana 66 with trample that when
it etbs you draw a card for each other
dinosaur you control so that's just one
extra card for them and now they're
completely tapped out so it looks like
we're going to be able to ulate to Fury
T's timate gives us an emblem that lets
us untap all of our permanence during
our opponent's untap step
and we get to draw a card on their draw
step two the turn comes to us and we
ultimate to Fury activate calender play
our second toy and activate calendar one
more time and pass the turn to our
opponent thanks to toy giving us some
extra life we are now on 30 so even if
our opponent swings at us we have plenty
of room to survive our opponent plays
another earthshaker dread Moore and a
IAH Hill's lke keeper and Swings in for
11 we activate calender one more time
putting it to
472 counters and during our turn we
activate the calendar two more times for
That Sweet 1,000 Point damage
win now I'd like to tell you that this
deck is great
but
oh come
on that's unfortunately not the case
control decks can interact with the
calendar and aggro decks can quickly
overwhelm us so while this deck is fun
to play I don't recommend putting all
your wild cards into it well that's
about it for this video what other decks
are you excited to play in lost cavins
of Exelon and let me know if you enjoyed
this gameplay styled video be sure to
like it if you enjoyed it and I hope to
see you in the next
one